Hôm nay, 2.3 mời, quân đội hàng của thương báo sẽ bị động khoảng 3.7 trăm binh sĩ.
Tham gia công thác bảo đảm ảnh dung trung thời gian giã dễ đàn thực tắc tệ tròa thái định dương.
Apak hai nghìn khúc trăm lắm.
Theo buộc tương lạnh tác chiến số 2 lực quân hàng quốc, các đơn vị đu trên khai chiến cả bà hướng, bộ không và biển.
Nhằm bảo vệ an toàn trước các đoàn đại biểu đến từ các nền kinh tệ thành viên.
Thành phố Kinh Trung, nơi tổ chua nhỉ, sẽ là khu bực trọng liền của chính dịch.
Lực lượng không quan trung đào có phía đổi cơ động số 5, đón tạn sân bây cô tệ ghiêm hệ, sẽ phố chích bảo vệ hoạt động dí chuyển của các đại biểu.
Chúng đỏ kể xác hành của cũng đánh nước mức cạnh báo anh nền, tại kêu chua lên cán nhất,
chừng mề cho hội nghi cấp cao các nhà lĩnh đạo kinh tệ Apak.
Dự kiến diễn xa và người bà miếm móc tháng mời mùi tháng mùi.